it is our last day of design week
although design's never going anywhere
from this show because it is my happy
place
but we want to send it off in a big way
and we recently challenged three
social media design superstars
to take this dresser from basic
to beautiful take a look
hi i'm jenny yolo from i spy diy
i renovate old houses here in milwaukee
wisconsin with my husband and document
the whole process
my favorite things are bold paint colors
spending way too much time at thrift
stores and diy decor
hi i'm carly alves with made by carly a
diy and home renovations blog where i
share my passion
for home decor and budget friendly diys
i love creating spaces in my home which
i call pockets of pretty that
are classic and affordable and i love
being able to share inspiration and
ideas along the way
my name is kate ahrens i am the founder
of whit and delight which is a lifestyle
brand that empowers
readers to design a life well-lived
i'm so excited about this project i have
all my supplies behind me i have chalk
paint i have wallpaper i have vintage
looking handles
i'm gonna get started doing some
sketches just with what i know is coming
um my kids are gonna help me probably
pick out the colors i'm gonna put them
all together to give this basic dresser
a makeover
so let's get started there goes nothing
i have just been informed that there is
a surprise waiting for us
um from the drew barrymore show so i'm
gonna go grab that and i'm gonna open it
in front of you
oh it's yellow pink
all right so um yellow yellow red
and pink
[Music]
that is so brilliant the kids handprint
i cannot wait to see these finished
dressers so let's meet our designers
please know that i am meeting
personal rock stars because that's what
designers are for me
kate ahrens carly alves and
jenny yolo
i am so excited to meet you guys
i just have to tell you that i'm such a
fan girl
um thank you for all that you do and
guide and influence
um everyone out there to make life
prettier to make every day better
so uh kate uh will you
show us your dresser and how you
approached the challenge
teach us so dresser's right behind me uh
i miss going to flea markets so i wanted
to bring a little bit of that quirky
essence into this dresser i had some
left
paint um and some really sweet knobs and
just felt that i could add a little bit
of little details to this
you know simple dresser and you know
bring some bring some cork to it
i mean i feel kind of bad that we threw
you a curveball of the yellow in this
challenge and yet
i'm so glad that we did because i love
this pink trim
because i don't often see trim in the
actual drawer
it's always on the dresser itself that
is brilliant
i also love that you combine two
different knobs i feel like people would
be very scared of that
um but making that top drawer its own
little entity
brilliant i love it i love it
i absolutely am in awe i always am
learning stuff and this is what's so
exciting
trim on the drawer itself
okay carly you deconstructed
and then reconstructed your dresser wow
okay may we see it how did it come out
teach us
so i truly believe that necessity is the
mother of invention
and that's kind of what starts all of my
creative projects
and when i received the dresser i said i
need something in my dining room to hold
my liquor so i
took the legs off i decided to use
wooden dowels to kind of elevate it and
it truly elevated the whole entire piece
i love the way it came out
i am flabbergasted right now
because you i think are showing people
the mentality of what you see
is not necessarily what it needs to be
and that is so liberating and so freeing
it really does sometimes take someone
else to
open our own eyes and your execution is
beautiful
i love what mechanism did you put in
there may i ask to hold the glasses
upside down like what really reminds us
of being at a restaurant
yeah so you can buy these little wooden
um wine glass hole it's actually a wine
glass holder
that you just screw one right to the top
it was super easy
okay i i also just being told it's easy
and doable is what gets people
out of their fear mode of oh i could
never do that
i cannot thank you enough that was
mind-blowing
okay jenny it's now your turn to show us
your dresser and walk us through your
design choices teach us
yup my dresser is right behind me i love
using chalk paint mostly because you
don't have to do much prep no sanding or
priming
and i really wanted to have this rich
eggplant color
that kind of mimics the bathroom right
next to it because i'm going to use this
as a linen closet um
and then i wanted to add some antique
vintage looking handles
and gilded the legs with some gold paint
just to make it look really rich
and then added a little wallpaper to the
inside for a pop of pattern
i want to focus on what you did
around the dresser as well because you
made the dresser
this neutral gorgeous colored star
but how you styled it changed everything
the picture frame that's sort of an old
antique art and a sort of beautiful
floral dried
branchy look and the candles you
really turn this up on its head and
i'm so impressed i really am you created
a really
beautiful sort of shaker antique moment
i
i love it thanks this corner is
definitely kind of instagram famous
it's had many different versions and i
just love styling it
it's just the light is beautiful too
well and you guys are
all very you know social media famous
and i'm so honored that you would come
on this show and this was just so much
fun thank you
so much for being here and if you want
to see even more design ideas from
kate carley and jenny go to our website
where we will be celebrating them on the
drewberrymore show.com
you